supercharge your buy torch training loop
with aging phase accelerate
there are multiple setups on which you
can run your training
it could be on cpu gpus tpus
distributed on one machine with several
devices or even several machines
often called nodes with multiple devices
on top of that there are new tricks to
make your training faster or more
efficient
like mixed precision and deep speed
each other's setup or training trick
requires you to change the code of your
training loop in one way or another
and to learn a new api all the setups
are enabled by the trainer api
and also several third-party libraries
that can help
the problem with those is that we can
feel like a black box
and that it might not be easy to
implement the tweak to the training loop
you need
accelerate has been designed
specifically to let you retain full
control over your training loop
and be as non-intrusive as possible with
just four lines of code to add to your
training loop
we are shown on the example of the
training loop video
accelerate will handle all the setups
and training tricks mentioned on the
first slide
it's only one api to learn on master
instead of 10 different ones
more specifically you have to import and
instantiate an accelerator object
that will handle all the necessary code
for your specific setup
then you have to send it the model
optimizer and data loaders you're using
in the prepare method this is the main
method to remember
accelerate endorsed device placement so
you don't need to put your batch on the
specific device you're using
finally you have to replace the lost
background line
by accelerate tor.backward loss
and that's all you need
accelerate also handles distributed
evaluation
you can still use the classic evaluation
loop such as the one we saw in the
training loop video
in which case all processes will perform
the full evaluation
to use a distributed evaluation you just
have to adapt your evaluation loop like
this
pass along the evaluation that allowed
us to the accelerator.prepper method
like for training then you can dismiss
the line that places the batch on the
proper device
and just before passing your predictions
on labels to your metric
use accelerator.gather to gather
together the predictions and labels from
each process
the distributed training script has to
be launched several times on different
processes
for instance one per gpu you're using
you can use the pytorch tools to do that
if you're familiar with them
but accelerate also provides an easy api
to configure your setup
and launch your training script in a
terminal
run accelerate config and also the small
questionnaire to generate a
configuration file with all the relevant
information
then you can just try and accelerate
launch followed by the bus to your
training script
in a notebook you can use the notebook
launcher function
to launch your training
you